[Music]
so I mean welcome to all of you to
session 11 on philosophers in the midst
of history this is a quarterly series
that we put up here at the Frank Lyon
Berg we've been doing it now this is the
third year for philosophers one ancient
one medieval one early modern and then
one late modern each year and what I try
to do is give a lecture they do a lot of
discussion of back and forth stuff that
puts them in their historical context
and so I pick people who were influenced
by their history and we're often
reacting to some interesting
developments within their time but there
are also people who made some sort of
impact on history you then all the
murder in the West I haven't done
anybody in the eastern part because I'm
not really competent when it comes to
you know like Chinese history but
there's enough going on we can probably
continue this series at least another
decade in it because there's so many
philosophers so we've done like you know
talking about Aristotle and Alexander
the Great or Plato an Athenian democracy
or boethius who didn't realize he was a
medieval because in his view the Middle
Ages hadn't yet started and in the
modern period we've looked at Thomas
Hobbes and renamed it hurts in previous
so they'll actually come up a little bit
and this one but this one is focused on
John Locke who's a really interesting
guy he's part of the this whole
development in in Britain and in larger
part in Europe and he has to do with you
know constitutional politics and
resistance to absolute monarchy he's got
his fingers and a lot of different pies
he made important contributions in
theory of Education to understandings of
religious liberty political thought as
well and then you know in philosophy
he's considered like a top-notch
first-rate figure as well in the mists
ecology and metaphysics so there's a lot
to say about him and he really isn't in
large part a creature of his own time he
also had a massive influence on the
early theorists the founding fathers who
put together the country so I think
nowadays if you talk about Locke a lot
of people associate him mostly with
conservatives but he would probably you
know they may be brought here today he
probably would be a bit standoffish to
both you know what we call liberals
today and what we call conservatives
today get in interesting discussions
with them so what I'm going to do in
this talk is first we'll look at is his
life in its historical context and I'll
make a few excursions into some of his
main ideas because they they tie in what
actually happened there's good reasons
why he did the things he did or wrote
the things he did at the time but he did
and then we'll look a bit more closely
at some of his key is just a smattering
cuz you know there's a fairly short talk
it's not a huge seminar so we can't get
into everything but we can look at some
of them and then you know what we'll
finish up by talking about some of his
influence not just on us here in America
but wider in the world and some of that
influence I'll give you a little bit of
a preview you can really tell that you
have made it in the world of culture
when people are criticised this guy
doesn't know what the hell he's talking
about it got this idea completely wrong
because you know you're important enough
to criticize that right and like not
only made contributions that a lot of
people are still you know interested in
today but he wound up being not one of
the guys who would get criticized by
everybody else so that's a way of
influencing people I also wanted to talk
at the start a little bit about
influence
before I get going though so I have a
tendency to talk and talk and talk and
talk so if there's anything that
something clear at any point you want to
ask a question or you've got a comment
you don't even have to raise your hands
say it them and it's not going to take
me off track I'm very good at like
getting myself back on track of the
teaching for over 20 years so I'm kind
of used to that but I do a tendency to
go on and on and on so if there's
something that you wanted before about
let me know it all fall right into that
so you know if you look at the timeline
he's born in 1632 a lot of stuff going
on in Europe at that time
and he dies it's very early in the view
century sentence you know for some of
his works get published after his death
quite a few that are published during
his his lifetime it was kind of common
for authors to have some of their works
published later especially if they were
considered that's not scandalous if
there was really any scandals in Locke's
case in the sense that we used that
ape-like problematic he had some some
views on Christianity that were rather
unorthodox at the time so you know
sometimes to keep under wraps David Hume
somebody else who is you know later on
but within his same tradition same sort
of deal a lot of his writings are
published after he dies and the monk is
born in England lives much of his life
in England
and then you know we'll have brief
excursions to France and to to Holland
and then occasionally to the new world
of the colonies and now he's living at a
time when this stuff over here I mean
this this wasn't even you know British
this was part of New France at one time
but the the the Eastern colonies they
were colonies they were nobody was
thinking about
and the fact that lock was was writing
that's much much later and he played an
important role in the southern colonies
and in setting some of their
institutions so we'll look at that in a
moment but you know if you look at his
his life he's a lot of his life he's he
actually students now students in a
somewhat attenuated sense where he was
registered and he actually got expelled
at one point later later on there's a
political reason for that what being a
student meant that he was going to be
influenced by either you know for or
against some of the other key thinkers
and movements at the time and one of the
movements that was particularly popular
is what we call scholasticism and you
know you probably you know this word
scholastic scholasticism was the
philosophy of the schools meaning the
essentially the philosophy of Aristotle
Middle Ages and they would you know kind
of update it as much as they could some
of it they're becoming you know keenly
aware that just in terms of physical
theory was not cutting it new you know
modern scientific ways of looking at the
world we're coming out and replacing it
but you know you would still read other
things of Aristotle the general approach
in some places was Aristotelian and it
was kind of you know you could think of
it as a risk of Helium life they weren't
they weren't representing the authentic
you know thought of Aristotle applied to
modern times they were kind of they were
the conservatives the intellectual
conservatives all the time
you also had some strands of what we
call Platonism coming from Plato that
had become popular during the
Renaissance and there were people in
England the Cambridge plainness who were
you know writing about Plato and
bringing up his ideas and trying to
at them to the wall that they were in
but a lot of the new let's call it the
center of gravity until actually was
coming from newer ways of approaching
much of which was not just influenced by
it but engaged very concretely with the
Natural Sciences so why will end up
being influenced by chemists he actually
winds up becoming a medical doctor
he gets a degree in license in that well
enough that he actually saves the Earl
of Shaftesbury at one time applying his
medical knowledge what we're seeing his
treatment and you know so some of the
ideas are coming from what we can call
materialist ways of looking at things
Thomas Hobbes earlier hardcore
materialists there were others not in
England but like Pierre Gassendi he was
an epicurean which is also a increased
strangely enough there were a number of
others out there who were taking this
this attitude you can understand the
world in terms of physical objects and
how they're put together their their
physical composition and they thought
that you could look at the human mind in
more or less the same what Hobbes has
this analogy that nowadays you read it
seems kind of quaint that like you know
within the human body to brand them feel
like a bunch of gears and things like
that but it was called the you know
mechanical viewpoint on things and so
you've got that going on and that tended
to reduce human beings to you know their
material circumstances and then you've
got this other associated with people
like
Grenada cards some of his his followers
Andrea interpreters then we can call
dualism they thought that you've got
material stuff you know like the body
you've got the body and you do have a
brain that you also have a mine or so
and that's something spiritual it's not
material they always had a hard time
explaining exactly how these things line
up with each other so they card heaven
sake you got this pineal gland in the
brain and sorta like a joystick and it
gets moved around by the animal spirits
and that produces you know thoughts it
not a very good explanation but you know
if we if we update it a bit we're still
struggling with these stainless
questions today why himself is going to
have a very innovative approach to some
of these but these are the background
people are debating this sort of stuff
and it's not just about you know the
body or how the mind works it's also
about thing some of the other great
debates of the time our politics matter
of fact you can never find a time where
people are in sort of unanimous
canonical things they're always arguing
that each other's just with what
arguments are they having and you know
nowadays were wrong for democracy right
there's probably a few people out there
who want to institute a monarchy of some
sort
they're pretty rare but at that time
there was a live question should you you
know should the King be the one who
really is in charge executive power
as we call it or should it be Parliament
should be something that's
representative not of everybody because
the legislative bodies at that time were
representative in the sense of me
thinking of today as a matter of fact
Locke would think that you know 90% of
the people who got voting should vote
because the creature it was time but
this is a really big struggle now that
if you have if you have an illegitimate
to the mix because remember this is
shortly after the process of reformation
you get all sorts of other things going
on because you know one of the key ideas
that they were working out is do we all
have to belong to the same church or a
religious organization in order to have
peace the Protestant Reformation set off
all these religious wars throughout
Europe the one in Germany killed about
half the population in France you had
reformed Protestants and Catholics
fighting with each other
Catholics eventually got the upper hand
but there was a lot of back and forth
the Spanish controlled the Netherlands
which were reformed the Spanish were
Catholic and they were fighting there
they fought wars against each other the
English had all sorts of stuff going on
and with the English it wasn't just you
know like like one set of Protestants
against the Catholics or maybe two sets
of Protestants like in Germany you had
you know Lutheran Protestants and then
you had informed Protestants good
Anabaptist but they had to get the hell
out of town because never gonna kill
them and then you have Catholics and
they you know fight against each other
right but in England you have a state
Church the Anglican Church of England
right and we've got Catholics still
around nobody's quite sure what to do
with them should you kick them out
shouldn't tolerate them you know don't
let them be in charge because I'd be
like with Queen Mary's in charge but
then you've got all these other
denominations up north you've got these
Scots Presbyterians or Calvinists you've
got these people that we call the
Puritans these days who were they does
anybody know what their background was
another here they also call
Congregationalists they were reformed so
they were following you know Calvin's
doctrine and why are they Puritans what
were they trying to make well that's
part but again this ties in with this
notion of community what they really
wanted to purify was the Church of
England they thought it was still too
Catholic so they want to get rid of all
of this other stuff so these for example
can you have a cloth on the altar right
Catholic Church of course
all sorts of sometimes very ornate altar
cloths the Anglicans were fairly
conservative as Protestants they
retained a lot of things at the older
church at hand and so the Puritans are
like you've got to get rid of that stuff
get rid of those candles get rid of this
get rid of that and now you can imagine
that made them kind of unpopular so
you've got the Puritan versus Anglican
thing going on with other denominations
appearing at that time like the Society
of Friends of the Quakers very small now
but back then there are quite a few of
them they were revolutionary Baptists in
their own day were persecuted by just
about everybody they got very very
radical in the eyes of many people and
so you mix that into the political
situation and now it's no longer about
Parliament and the king because now
everybody's got all these different
religious things going on - yeah the
question is well can you actually have
toleration which means letting people
belong to different denominations of
practice what they want what are they
gonna all get up in each other's
business and start you know verbally
raising hell with each other and causing
trouble so maybe you have to crack down
and say listen everybody's got to do
this for like think about you know of a
silly example but you know why do we
have uniforms and some schools what are
some of the justifications exactly and
then no but is it sort of like if you
guys can't get along nobody gets
privileges everybody's stuck with the
same thing my grandpa used to do
something there like my uncle's still
complain about they would very rarely
get to go on trips they're always trips
going out to Canada yeah for some reason
he had the idea that in a restaurant if
everybody ordered the same dish the food
would get there quicker
no of course no it doesn't but he would
make everybody decide on one dish and so
there would be big fights one person
wants spaghetti another Kristen wants
you know meatballs you know and they
would all have to agree on one dish that
they would all get which probably
created more colors right so I mean this
is sort of the background to what's
going on with Lockett and so in England
you've got this firmament of stuff going
on in France like I said the Catholics
got the upper hand but you know the
Protestants they were doing pretty well
for a while some places like Switzerland
it would be up to the each Canton so you
have Catholic Canton's and reformed
Canton's Germany then you had to hash
out something over the course of this
long war the Netherlands were the
nothing ones were an interesting place I
should tell you a little bit about this
because not only did Locke really enjoy
going there so to Descartes
the reason they liked it was because the
Dutch even though they they were
reformed they arrived at the point where
they like we've just got to have
toleration everybody's got to be allowed
to do their own thing so long as you
don't get so long as you don't try to
impose something on somebody else and I
think that has been part of their
culture for a very long time it was part
of what made them attractive to
intellectuals and probably led to a lot
of the success as a very small country
they enjoyed it so if we if we look at
the timeline right I broken into three
things John Locke's life and some of the
other intellectual contributions in
Europe and the British history which
includes some some history of other
places as well you notice Locke is you
know growing up around the time that
dick hurt is becoming famous for writing
these things Milton is writing we think
about it primarily because the poetry
that he actually made
very important contributions in terms of
political and educational tracks and
then there's the outbreak of the civil
wars in England and in the the end of
the Civil War Charles the first loses
the king is gone England becomes a
republic it becomes ruled by this guy
Oliver Cromwell and this is a huge huge
change Oliver Cromwell's pirita so the
Puritans and the Presbyterians are more
or less in charge it's tough for the
Anglicans under them it's tougher yeah
for the Catholics who are still there
around this a little bit later than that
the Treaty of Westphalia as the 30 Years
War in Germany so things are starting to
sort themselves out
Cromwell dies in 1658 around the time
that Locke is finishing up his school so
he's there in we could call it
revolutionary England right and his son
his son takes over and unfortunately as
is the case of many families talent
doesn't always pass on genetically
any of these not particularly good so
there's a restoration of the monarchy
with them within two years under this
guy charles ii and now i mean you can
understand if you're the king right and
your dad got executed and you know you
see these other guys in charge you're
probably not going to want to keep a lot
of room open for other people
participating in things particularly
since parliament where some of the
people who are causing all of this this
Furman's so there's this attempt to sort
of clamp down anything that's viewed as
revolutionary or even you could say in
our terms today progressive there's an
act of uniformity that gets past that
reimpose 'as the anglican church as the
official church
in England and for a while there's
there's very little toleration of other
churches now meanwhile walk is you know
moving around within the university
system he becomes a lecturer
when he was about 29 years old teaches
Greek rhetoric and moral philosophy you
notice he starts attending these other
lectures that people are given he means
you know Robert Boyle boy asses they
they actually were connected together
and he begins writing some of his own
course and then he is starting to get
involved in politics himself he winds up
being a secretary this embassy sent to
the elector of Brandenburg in my
solution where is that well the little
German states and it's it's going to be
important because a lot of those German
states are going to be lined up with
England definitely he gets his medical
license and around the same time Great
Fire of London takes place and then he
joins with this guy who's going to be
incredibly important not just for
Locke's history of the French history
his name is Anthony Ashley Cooper but we
know him as the Earl of Shaftesbury okay
you say well wheat here I don't know the
hell this guy is right then that's fine
he was he wasn't there then there were a
whole bunch of girl Shaftesbury's after
him too so you know which one wasn't
right well he was the first one and
being an Earl is a noble title he was he
went from being you know within sort of
one realm of the elite into another
realm he got to take hurt in
policymaking at the highest levels so
why became a secretary and not to some
sort of secretary where he's just like
sitting outside taking calls okay kind
of secretary who is like his right-hand
guy
handles his correspondence whose
accompany give on trips who's getting to
see how the political situation sorts
itself out who's handling important
details those sorts of things these are
you could call them all sorts of
concrete situations of political
argument and then real action
Shaftesbury was kind of badass this time
she ones if he winds up in exile and he
doesn't wind up in exile just because
he's like well you know they're gonna
take my stuff so I better get out of
here other things in the English Civil
War right it was the Royalists versus
Parliament and the parliamentary side
wins and then you get cromwell's
take over Jasper he was originally a
Royals or Cooper he was originally
royalist sees the writing on the wall
and sees that Cromwell is going to be
there works for problem so he's
interested in doing what he thinks is
the right thing for England itself and
he becomes affiliated with what's going
to become later the Whig party in these
these people who are progressives they
favorite Parliament they favor
toleration later on in time they'll
become associated with free trade at
that time interaction for protectionism
and it was the Royalists who were for
the free trade sometimes there's
flip-flops in these things but Cooper is
is on the scene and then when the King
comes back he now works with the King
but he is pretty suspicious of him and
one of the things that he really wants
to make sure doesn't happen is the
British monarchy becomes absolute the
way that has happened in France he
doesn't want something that he sees his
despotism he sees a couple different
risks with us one is charles ii himself
can prone to that sort of thing but
there's also these issues about
who's gonna be in charge after this guy
dies and one of the people who's in the
succession right after him is a Catholic
and they you know they didn't want a
strong Anglican in there they sure as
hell don't want to count because that
would mean in their view the Pope
getting to call the shots they would
just be just like Spain or France you
know so Shaftesbury you know it's being
a little facetious and calling it the
baddest but it really it was he took
part in plots plots to kill the king and
you know rebellions things so he's you
know I just kind of swashbuckling some
in some respects you know this thing was
right about this being suspicious yeah I
mean that's the thing just about
everybody would be would be rational to
be suspicious of somebody who doesn't
completely share their convictions
Hobbes talks about this so let me let me
go a little bit of Thomas Hobbes had
this uh
view that we you know he's one that
coined the phrase the life of human
beings outside of government or the
state of nature is nasty brutish and
short right and why is it nasty brutish
or because we can't rely on anything to
keep us from getting into conflict so he
thought there were three main causes of
human conflict one is what he called
competition so if I see you've got a
nice place I want your place I go to the
tacky
right if I've got a nice place you'll do
the same thing or anything else that
you've got now if you know that I'm
going to do that that you would be
rational to attack me first and that's
what he calls diffidence
we would call strategic thinking right
so if you know that I'm going to be
prone to M being new and taking your
stuff then why not tell me first
now I also know that you know that I'm
that way so you see how this is
rationing up and creating a very Powder
Keg situation it gets even worse the
third cause for human
is what he calls vanity so not only do
we have these you know reasonable
strategic reasons for getting in the
conflict I also want you to like like me
and think I'm a swell guy and laugh at
my jokes and if you don't I'm gonna you
know want to attack you the same way and
so you put all this together it's
rational instead of nature to look at
every other person as a threat
the state of nature doesn't just mean
like living out there you know like in
tents or something you know well I got
survivor you guys remember that show it
means any case where you don't have a
shared system of social expectations and
norms that can be enforced by some sort
of authority so in in the England you're
right in the England that that lock is
growing up in Hobbes is doctrine at
least the effort of it can seem to make
some good sense now how does the answer
to that you need a super strong
sovereign who can you know lay down the
law and as a matter of fact not only
should there they have a monopoly on
force they should have a monopoly on
ideas nobody should get to teach
anything other than what the king and
software Queen herself whatever you want
to call it what they deemed to be the
right dr. Marquez against the lock is on
the the other side and so is Shaftesbury
going back to his life so Locke is also
involved with as I remarked earlier
southern colonies
he helps draft the fundamental
constitutions of Carolina we'll talk
about that in a bit he's secretary to
the council trade and plantations for a
certain amount of time and these are you
know you know the British crown it
legally sort of like ordered all these
plantations right but you have British
subjects in them and then you have
people like Locke where shafts went
overseas or the other guys involved so
he took an important role in determining
what the actual life of Colin
look plantation areas so Shaftesbury is
elevated to Earl the King thinks that he
can thereby sort of get his his
acquiescence you know it can bring it
into the fold
doesn't work at all now he's just kept
more power
yeah chance Murray winds up getting I
was it from the office and now he
inference about the opposition he
actually collaborates with this guy my
mouth who another royal title who leads
a rebellion at one point and then
there's there's another thing that
happens so not only do you have like the
Whigs and the royal party squaring off
against each other
you saw the Catholics in the background
the Catholics are getting kicked around
by everybody pretty much and there's the
Popish plot and it's revealed and it's
all these executions of Catholics more
crackdowns and so you know when you
crack down on Catholics that then you
can also crack down on other people as
well so you can crack down the Catholics
a bit like one side of the spectrum and
the more radical Protestants have been
another side so you can crack down on
all of them and walk is seeing those
sorts of things when he is when all of
this is going on he starts writing this
is really important were called to
Wealth's two important words the two
trees of government why don't you know
why didn't we see a mark because we put
them together in one book often times
when we published them but they are two
actual treatises and he's writing these
in response to some of the claims that
are being made for absolute monarchy so
he's writing these to provide a way of
thinking about politics that would be a
different mom and it winds up being like
I said incredibly influential on our own
political system later and now you
notice in
and there the column about British
politics at the time you have these
different crises going on the exclusion
crisis the Whigs are trying to exclude
this Catholic heir from the throne they
convene Oxford Parliament every part of
that's got its own name you know and so
the Oxford Parliament is is convened
they're trying to pass some stuff the
King dismisses them and dismisses
doesn't mean like saying oh you guys
could leave that means like you guys
have better get the hell out of here
we're gonna tell you Jasper he winds up
getting accused of treason he gets off
one of the I'll tell you another case or
a quirky thing so you've got all this
social conflict going on right and
people were taking different sides just
like you know today we have this
factionalized political system you know
if you're a Republican you probably
can't count Democrats to treat you guys
if you're a Democrat you probably can't
count on Republicans to treat NIH's
these days maybe in some circumstances
but it's pretty polarized so if you were
getting accused of a crime it was really
important who the jury because the jury
would gets it you know quit you or I
find you guilty a lot of people would
get found guilty if they're innocent if
they're the wrong faction now who do you
think he actually got to assemble the
jury well who would who in particularly
it's not like our system exactly they're
gonna think probably the judge its
sheriff so if you had a sheriff who is a
wig and you were a big you're home free
that was the case for a Shaftesbury
these tact of the grand jury full of
other wigs and they're like this guy's
out of here you know so that's the way
work but there were a lot of people a
lot of the sheriff's were actually
supporters of the king and then that
they would pack it with you know follow
supporters of them
we could get executed or thrown in
prison he doesn't wind up in the Tower
of London for a bit before that and then
there's a court coup against the Whigs
and the City of London they're clamping
down again and Shaftesbury please -
hamat walk is going to follow him fairly
soon and Jasper he is going to actually
die in Holland and then there's this
week right how supply yeah that made
some you know like maybe kind of a fun
thing head to my house probably didn't
associate with whisky or something like
that it wasn't the right house was
actually this fortified building and the
king is traveling to go to these races
and they knew that he was going to come
be coming back on this path so they like
wait up all these munitions guns I don't
mean there's like you know rifles and
stuff cannons they they were gonna like
blow this guy and all of his followers
out of it as often happens with plots
that somebody doesn't keep their mouth
shut
it's discovered and then actually the
King doesn't go that way anyway and so
that causes more clamp downs as well
Locke actually has to go back to Holland
because he's in exile as a suspect in
the plot they they expel them from
Christchurch College in absentia as a
punishment for all of this and then he
starts you know writing more things he
writes the letter concerning toleration
a very short piece very important you
notice that he's gonna write several
other letters concerning toleration 2nd
to 3rd and then there's this this this
glorious revolution before that Charles
dies James the person 7th is coming from
from Scotland the King James will be
associated the King James Bible he comes
in blue mated the 14th you guys are
with him the Sun King here evokes
toleration and Francie revokes the Edith
Edith EDX is a great dance and I start
persecuting the the Protestants there
again and then there is this glorious
revolution a new King comes in takes
over these are the ones that we have
today the Royal House right well then
you know France and England start to go
to war meanwhile was locked he's
reviewing works he's publishing
treatises he's he's still involved in
politics to some degree but not to the
degree that he was that while
Shaftesbury was alive he's still doing
some work in terms of the colonies and
plantations you notice like he winds up
in 1696 so you know less than 10 years
before he dies he's appointed to the
Board of Trade and plantations
he doesn't report on the government to
Virginia so he's getting more and more
involved in these things and then you
know what he dies you know the good
right age in 1704 and he leaves behind a
massive legacy and the legacy is
primarily an intellectual one but it's
one that has some big practical effects
so before I go into any of that I've
talked at you for quite a while you have
any questions about all this history
business comments things that makes you
think about other of those launching
some of his key ideas Oh his works yeah
okay so let the action that's let's jump
right into that you know it's not just
the Constitution it's the Declaration of
Independence the notion that you know
all better you know given recorded or
however we want to put it in alienable
rights that wasn't unique to
he's using that language he does think
it comes from from a creator some
Jefferson Jefferson was actually very
influenced by lock key phrase life
liberty pursuit happiness right for
Locke he talks on the second trees about
life liberty and property and why you
know why did Jefferson change it well
because the way they understood property
is property is really essential to the
pursuit of happiness he's got a very
expansive consumption probably the
notion of self ownership is in part
coming from line and then you know
there's other language in the
Declaration and in the Constitution
that's coming from Locke's Second
Treatise you know it's notional
intolerable abuses which is why we
revolted against the British king well
if you look at the Second Treatise you
can say the whole second half of it is
really concerned with this question when
is it okay to overthrow the existing
power structure and impose a new one and
who gets to do it you know it's the
people so that those are all ideas that
are that are coming to us from Locke you
know you could have gotten from other
places but but in point of fact these
guys did read Locke
that's all they're really influenced by
him so let's let's start by talking
about that politically they mentioned
two treatises on gum that's very
important we tend to read just the
second treatise the first treatise is
directed primarily against this kind of
robert filmer unless you're a scholar
and you probably don't read in or even
you know hear about him and i don't know
too many people who actually do work on
the first treatise but the second trees
is very common I'll actually be teaching
it this the semester for undergraduates
basically an intro philosophy class
because there's a lot of cool stuff in
there that we can sink our teeth into
he's against the absolute monarchy why
would I be against absolute monarchies
it just you know buy us some time
he provides arguments what's what's
wrong with this well it's a lot of
problems I mean succession is one of
them you know that's a problem with any
organization how do you how do you do
succession planning and when you've got
you know this monarchic old way of doing
it you may not get the best talent
necessarily you have a very limited pool
but the idea was that there's something
wrong with having monarchy in that sense
not that you know you can still have a
constitutional monarchy like that Brits
and some of the other Europeans do today
they walk would be cool with that
but there's no room there's no scope for
the people to decide and so Locke is not
himself a Democrat in the classic sense
but he is for representative government
and he makes a good argument for that
he's also for something he calls a
social contract this is an idea I think
we're all familiar with what is the
social contract say somebody's violating
the social contract yeah very very basic
things right like we should pick up our
trash right and see somebody throwing
stuff on the ground like hey you know
trash cans over there they're like screw
you
you know I have a perfect right to throw
throw things on the ground of your life
you know we live in a society here buddy
you know there could be a lot of
different ways this goes but what are
you doing there making it appeals there
are certain norms that we should all
follow and why should we follow those
norms is it just well we'd like to make
rules and you know it's cool to follow
them know it's there they make for a
better life for all of us right the
social contract should be something that
teens account
good and when one way to look at the
social contract that that Hobbes and
Locke and other people did at the time
was when when we enter into the social
contract we are giving up certain rights
in the state of nature we have a right
to do whatever the hell we want you know
and to do it any anybody else so if
we're all in the state of nature if I
want to kill all of you and take your
stuff that's that's bad for you but it's
not bad overall something morally it's
just bad for you but once we make that
that basic agreement if I even like
cross into your property without your
permission I am doing something I don't
have the right to do and I and I give up
my rights precisely so that you'll give
up your rights I won't kill you you
don't kill me I keep my hands off your
stuff you keep your hands off my stuff I
don't we might make a different thing I
don't say bad things about you on
Facebook that aren't true you don't say
bad things about me on Facebook right or
Twitter or whatever some people probably
leave but a lot was for this social
contract any thought why would we leave
the state of nature which is not too bad
it's not like a Hobbesian state of
nature we're all gonna kill each other
most people in the state of nature can
kind of get along he thought like the
Native Americans were living in the
state of nature other peoples in other
areas were why would we leave it well
because there's going to be some
advantage to some security we can build
things and this is where we get to the
idea of property and why property is so
important you know if you think about
like when we go camping now we're not
really getting to the natural state okay
as we bring a tent and cooking stove and
some people have like solar things to
charge their iPhones yeah there's
nothing to the music they bring beer out
there should come out the camp's like
you know some people just have an RV you
know hook the hose up to things so
that's not really roughing it in the
true sense you know if you often just
cannot make yourself homeless apart for
a while
it quits being pleasant pretty quick and
there's not a lot to eat you know if
there was you know let's say you see
squirrels you don't really know I'll
kill them and turn them into food what
the hell kind of life is anyway right
nature is you know provides us with lots
of stuff but Nature doesn't package it
for us
so who does it us we engage in what this
is what we call a labor theory of
property in picking up all those acorns
that I'm gonna turn into a calf flower
which I don't think it's probably that
all that appetizing but a lot of people
did that and then making it into bread
that's mine why is it mine why do those
become mine as soon as I pick them up
because I am contributing labor to that
that's what allows me to say that so
when I see a deer and I take a shot at
the deer that's my dear before you could
have deer on one if you want to take a
shot at could be your you but once I've
actually laid claim to it it becomes
mine and I have a right to it in the
state of nature you could knock me on
the head and take my stuff in the social
contract in civil society you can't do
that or you can but I'll call the cops
they'll enforce the rules right and so
the the main reason this goes back to
that life liberty and property the
social contract is there a good society
a well-organized rational way of living
is there to make it possible for us to
maintain our life to maintain our
freedom that's a Liberty is and to make
property that we required now the
original bit of property that you own is
you so really what you're doing is
you're mixing your property in with some
other bit of property and you're turning
it into an extension of you this is you
know a notion of us as property owners
as property creators as as generating
all sorts of things that are down buying
for yours and you might say well that's
fine but you know what about this thing
I mean it just came to me I may push a
few buttons on it but that doesn't make
it mine well your purchased right you
exchanged some money for it for this but
we're doing all the value of this come
from they came from all these steps
people doing things to these raw
materials and then taking those new
products and using them as raw materials
of contributing their property so if you
if you think about it that way you made
some wall hello this actually belongs to
the workers back in China who you know
contributed all that labor we don't have
very good lives making the iPhones and
lockwood's it no no no because that was
purchased you see the manufacturer the
owners of the iPhone factories got those
people to exchange their labor for money
why didn't know why the hell would they
do something like that
well because money allows you'd serve
like a way to preserve value you can
swap it for other things and Locke has a
whole argument in the second treatise
about why it's rational to do this and
why it's not rational to not accept
money or why people those already get to
some so you know I think we can see it
recognizes a little bit problematic side
why people who don't participate in that
money economy are really irrational
they're not using natural
sources the way they autism maybe we
could push them off of those natural
resources and take them for those of us
who are actually going to do something
you know Locke says Native Americans got
a feel or a battle because it's not even
the feel you know you get some deer and
rabbit berries out of it now imagine
that same field cultivated by a farmer
it would produce 20 times the amount so
they don't really have claimed to push
them up and this is one of the arguments
that did you use against so that's you
know that's one set of ideas having to
do with you know money labor the
political system any questions about
that or comments about that before
talking a little bit about toleration so
it's kind of you could put it in the
same perspective of what's happening
nowadays yeah but it's kind of the
system creating itself and who creates
the rules to say what the answer on what
isn't this kind of this song system is
that's what they're there's a good point
and one of the things that you bring up
is there Locke distinguishes between
executive power and legislative power
legislative power is where we all get
together and we we elect representatives
and those drummers and those make the
decisions right so like let's say we
have a company and we all we're all
shareholders we elect some people to be
the forward they make the decisions if
we don't like what they're doing we say
get out of here and dance good for like
setting agendas and say nothing of the
executive power which you know we
associate with like the presidency or
here in the state of the governor and
all these agencies that do things and
they're the ones who do the day-to-day
work implementing the will of the
legislature and they're the ones who
make decisions in crises and why knows
of course from experience just look at
the timeline that the executive will
tend to take on too many privileges
create crises do things their way and
subvert the will of the legislature and
so you know that's why you can revolt
against the cake when when you know will
the Legislature's been computer yeah
and so you could you look at this in
terms of the need for two different
kinds of authority you know anything you
can't get you can't get by without any
executive you can't legislate every
single thing it just takes too long and
there's crises that come up and you do
need somebody to make decisions just
like in a business you do need a CEO who
can make a decision it can't always go
to the board or like in a college you
know you need a president or a chance or
whoever's make the decision the Board of
Trustees pretty hopeless these days oh
did you have a thought about the
judicial yeah yeah the judges I mean he
doesn't he doesn't talk about like the
three branches of government we got that
idea from Montesquieu but he does think
that juries are very important and that
judges are important to you and there's
discussions in there about the need to
be impartial if you want to actually
have a functioning social contract the
judges cannot be deciding their own
cases because there's a clear conflict
of interest there and they need to be
fair they need to be impartial or else
people start to lose confidence in the
system anything and we see this you know
in some other countries where the
judicial branch just gets gutted
interestingly there are some countries
they are Supreme Court right doesn't get
to decide an awful lot they didn't pass
on some of the stuff they could decide
like the gerrymander in case they
Wisconsin baby honestly decided not to
do everything yeah in India the Supreme
Court can actually call it the question
Korea not preemptively but but
proactively the actions of the executive
branch
so Amanda Lee if our Supreme Court was
more active they're like we don't like
what you're doing in terms of what the
president does but Secretary of the
Interior or something like that we're
going to review this and tell you you
can or can't do this that's that's
different different model of the
judicial branch has more power
well Locke doesn't doesn't have it in
there for him though
judges are essentially there for the
legislature executive
well it's talk about toleration so we
need tolerate something what do you do
what was what are synonyms yeah exactly
you put up with if you ever have to say
I'm tolerating somebody you don't like
them you don't think what they're doing
you don't agree with them but you're not
going to kill them or throw them in jail
or censor that do all those sorts of
things so this is a big big issue that
was being hashed out and I think you
know here in the United States in the
present and even more or less in the
first world in general now some
exceptions I think most people you know
they see some value to toleration of
people who they don't agree you know
we're not if you're a Republican you may
want from Hillary Clinton in jail but
you don't want throw all Democrats in
jail and vice versa you know Democrats
and they see Trump go but they don't all
Republicans go off the stage that wasn't
something you could take for granted
Becca
and so Locke is making an RV
for toleration specifically about
religion because religion was probably
the most contentious issue and so in his
letters concerning toleration he is
writing an argument and if they're very
sharp read them quite quite easily
he says a few things one is that one of
the problems at the time was they would
they would make decisions where they
would push the decision to secular
leaders about like what church is right
or you know who should be allowed who
should malonic said listen when we get
into this religion stuff or supernatural
stuff the secular leaders are not
competent to judge maybe somebody is
competent to judge but it isn't the
president's not the King it's not it's
not judge and you know here in America
because of the way things have turned
out in our Supreme Court cases we have
something like this if you look back
over like landmark decisions they they
actually had to decide that there would
be no definition of religion so you
can't actually say this counts as
religion this doesn't count as religion
and they refuse to discriminate between
like which which interpretations they
had to do this because people were like
hey you need to make a decision to focus
so block says listen that's that's just
not gonna work it's it's a sort of
non-starter and then even if you can try
to force a single true religion you're
just going to create more problems
because you cannot compel the leaf and
the more that you like push down on
people and say you are going to believe
Anglicanism is the true church the more
they're like we'll screw this this is
this is clear they of if you really need
to hit me over the head to convince me
of it I think there's probably something
you know fishy about this right it's
kind of you could say no way it's kind
of like the rejection of state religion
as a kind of cult-like behavior right
and then the other thing that he said
was even if you
don't change hurts and minds and you
think well listen we're just gonna have
a state religion everybody is to buy
into this we don't care what you really
think or what you do behind closed doors
been in public you're going to all agree
with this he said that's not gonna work
anything you know he can appeal to like
the history that he's living through
where people try to do that but he also
makes a philosophical argument saying
you cannot expect this to be a winning
strategy now there are some exceptions
so I guess you would think well
everybody should get to practice their
religion so who do you think lock left
out
Catholics are one of the big nerves no
why why do you think this is it just we
don't like those papists you know too
old-fashioned there's that there's one
other thing
monix says that any church that will not
acknowledge the legitimacy of other
churches can't be tolerated so because
they're being intolerant they can't be
and you know at the time I mean you know
the Catholic Church has you know they
would they wouldn't say they've changed
their position on so fits in
successfully you know
articulated their position in much more
thoughtful ways but at the time there
were Catholics who were engaging in you
know plots to kill the king or
Parliament you know there were a lot of
things a lot of bad blood between them
and they can look across the channel and
see what was happening in France and we
don't want that circle so Catholics
right who else
atheist why not
why can't you tolerate atheists I think
it's because they can't this is still an
argument that people make today
you know they can't find to the solfege
contractors ya know why not why she how
does the foundation of morality yes so
you can't trust them when they take it
off because you know anybody else if
they take it off this is really placing
a lot of credence rayna's so there's a
lot of people who go to church take
walls and they break them all the time
but I do the reasoning is well you can't
trust them but they think oh they don't
believe in anything so you know forget
it
and yeah they can't they can't actually
be part of the social contract so forget
the atheist forget the Catholics any
other Christian churches and there were
some some religious sects the radical
part of the Reformation who really were
very you know exclusion area that we've
got the only right interpretation some
of them actually made people convert or
there face consequences usually they
want to get killed or the Calvinists or
the Catholics or the Anglicans that's
why there's you know when it comes to
the Anabaptist tradition they're all
very peaceful all the world like ones
got killed
oh that was that but there's one other
group that like excludes from toleration
yes now what made you say that because
according to at least some of their
interpreters they can either tolerate
that's and that's exactly where they
lock slot and lock you know Europe
invented content with Islam for quite a
while so he includes them in there
he doesn't talk about anybody else those
are those are the groups that you can't
have well but the general principle is
anybody who you can't rely on to be
following this little contract or
tolerating other people they can't be
shown toleration but everybody else you
should be shown toleration
pretty interesting argument
what else Oh education I mentioned that
Locke was quite as it was he the first
one to bring up toleration or the banal
now there are there are many others too
but it's what makes his version well
providing that argument that's sort of
like you know listen this isn't gonna
work and even if it did this isn't gonna
work and even if it did ok this isn't
going to work
so there's a kind of rigor to it a lot
of the tracks concerning toleration at
the time this is intended to be why the
lines up you know here's why not
tolerating is so bad because look at
what happened to these people these
people these sort of like accumulating
you know some of these books like these
uh books about my religion is always a
bad thing today in the new atheist
movement kind of do that they just
accumulate a lot of you know examples
and that's interesting but it's not it's
not by itself persuasive right it's not
a refutation of the actual argue yeah
that's just saying oh there's only thing
yeah I'm saying here's a point by point
analysis like here's this yeah I mean
I've been some of the books do do that
but but they sometimes they haven't too
many examples you lose your audience I
won't say this to about the reception of
the first letter consider the first
letter concerning toleration one of the
guys are criticized it said that it was
a papist plot to try to sow dissension
within the Protestant churches and that
clearly you know it was it was a way to
try to cause trouble in England so that
the Catholics could sweep in and take
over that kind of a funny response to it
you know Locke was like yeah and they
knew Locke that they could you know say
well clearly he's not a Catholic he's
he's way
a more progressive than the Anglicans or
even Puritans other people he was he's
pretty unorthodox when I came to
religion he doesn't appear to have
believed in the doctrine of original sin
which most people did at the time you'd
be given a lot of trouble for saying the
wrong things about about the nature of
the second person of the Trinity you
know the Sun Jesus he appears to held
something that in earlier times was
considered a heresy the area in here
you've got the father doesn't know the
Sun is Lord Jesus is just sort of a
really great guy you know not not God
himself but he'd also didn't say a home
which is probably smart if some people
accused him of that some people thought
it was a deist oh yeah I've got a
Creator God who creates a whole universe
somewhere yeah like Thomas Jefferson
definitely so think about if you took
all the rituals of Christianity way and
just kept the ethical content and the
notion of there being a creator
introduces regularity into nature so
that we can discover how it works your
natural laws right therefore what does
the physical world in that are that's
that's what dazzles so there's no
there's no point in prayer than the
point in rituals and they do believe it
that there is a God but it's not a god
along the same lines as traditional
Christianity interestingly one of the
founding fathers Thomas Paine right he
writes a book during the French
Revolution called the age of reason and
the reason he writes it is he's over him
France and the French had revolted
against King Church and the nose they
killed one
so his worry that goes to the atheist
thing his worry was if the French don't
replace Catholicism with some sort of
religion that they're all gonna become
atheists and then it's just gonna be
like a bloodbath
who knows what the hell you know you
can't you can't rely on it so he writes
a book called the age of reason which is
specifically oriented towards trying to
convert the French to Dean's because he
thought well this will be rational and
they'll be just fine
but that's let's talk a little bit about
some less political less religious
things I mentioned that he was an
important guy in education he wrote he
wrote a book that became very very
popular
it's called thoughts concerning
education cirno's a bunch of letters
that he writes and he puts it into a
book and some of the stuff that he's
saying there is not radically new
they've been said by people like nothing
before but it just didn't have a popular
audience like somehow a lot of being in
the right place at the right time and it
becomes very very popular it gets read
for four century afterwards as a key
document and one of the key ideas he had
that made its way into philosophy and
then also into psychology is what we
call Association ideas I think this is
something that we all now take for
granted this is the conception that when
you're look the the things that happen
to you and the mindset that they give
what we say the lessons that teach you
right about the world that who you are
like that those for our basic way making
sense of new information so just to use
one example that comes up a lot in terms
of bullying right when when your kid
gets bullied one of the risks that's
involved in that it's not just that it
damages their self-esteem which it which
is based on association of ideas people
really like me they wouldn't treat me
like crap right so I must be crap so you
know I'll just look at myself that way
the big danger is that they turn into a
boy the next time around like what I was
in the army
basic training I remember you know we'd
all agree we all have been doing stupid
stuff very arbitrary and a lot of it was
done kind of sadistically by the drill
sergeants and some of them were actually
really good guys but just complete jerks
and they were you know sort of three
basic reactions one is just people just
suck it up and keep their mouths shut
and another people who would be like man
when I get my surgeon stretch I'm never
treating privates like this I am gonna
do things differently that there were
the guys who would say man I can't wait
to get my sergeants stripes so I can
push something else's face in the mud
I'm gonna be even worse than these guys
now why did people have these different
reactions Locke would say probably has
to do it their childhood you know the
guys who had that third reaction you
know their ideas were formed in a
certain way so how do our ideas get
formed it's partly through you know
actually teaching yeah but a lot of it
is to do with our habits the things that
we do over and over again so think about
you know when we send kids off to
kindergarten what did what do they have
to learn there I mean a finger-painting
that's that's great but it's not a
important life skill but putting the
paint away that is right what else it
gets taken back those
that was cool or it could have a snack
but you know you're also learning you
take a nap at this time the teacher
tells me to take a bath so you know
these habits be and children are much
more valuable than adults according to
the same yeah so you want to pay very
close attention to the association of
their ideas people weren't doing that at
the time it's kind of slip shot do
whatever with your kids yeah and then
you don't figure out what to do with
them when they turn you know twelve over
sixty eight or something then they go to
school then you start trying to Foreman
but they're already so screwed up but
who knows what's hurting about it so
there's there's that he also redefines
the notion of virtue he says that virtue
is this capacity to deny a person their
own desires to cross their own
inclinations and purely follow what
reason directs as best even though their
appetite or desire leads the other way
so self-control right
but notice is framed in a very negative
way lock looks at little human beings
children as being basically potential
adults you want to get the child out of
that as quickly as possible so they can
become rational self control and maybe
not screw up their lives that's that's
locking education he also says something
really quite quite interesting in the
remarks concerning education that could
make us be a little less optimistic
about the Second Treatise of government
the Second Treatise of government he
talks to us like we're all totally
rational you know we can all see that
these are good arguments they don't need
the king you know if you have one it's
okay to revolt against them because
we're rational human beings we can get
ourselves out of the state of nature
into the social contract in thoughts
concerning education he's got a
different take affect most people are
not rational they're screwed up you know
they they are not because of their
education didn't to fit them for you
know being a citizen they really don't
know what the hell they're doing and
they're subject to all sorts of stupid
prejudices
and superstitions being taken advantage
of so there's a bit of attention there
you know what would the remedy for that
better education
he also he's known in philosophy as sort
of one of the fathers of what we call
empiricism the terminators are familiar
with material that's probably more
common what would it mean when we say
something's empirically scientifically
proven so it could be scientifically
proven but not necessarily sure
observing show comes from observation
through experience basically
experiential is another but and the idea
is the empiricism Locke talks about the
human mind as being what he calls a
tabula rasa blank slate everything that
we know comes either from things that
came in from the outside or what we did
with that stuff wants it got inside but
there was nothing in our hands you know
they're literally empty babies right and
they got filled with stuff and then we
we took those ideas and operated them so
you know think about when have you ever
seen nothing
yeah right you can't see nothing can't
show me right but why do we have a
conception of them somebody like the car
could say well you have this innate idea
it's implanted in your mind it's just
part of our sort of mental architecture
sort of you might think about it in
technological terms a sort of basic
hardware right with like there's no
hardware there's just the mechanism
itself that gets you know created by all
this information coming in so how do we
get our idea about nothing
well imagine everything that is now just
imagine that being common now you get
the idea of nothing or just imagine all
the different single things that you can
come up with and put them out of your
mind
now you've got nothing so that's a what
he calls a complex one that's produced
through reflection or abstraction
thinks that we can be or a book that's
about this thick is sa concern
concerning human understanding which was
used by the way as a textbook for a
while in a lot of places he tries to
provide an account of how our ideas come
to us like how do we form this idea how
do we form this thing how do we form
this thing yeah he's trying to give me
an account so he is really somebody who
gets empiricism off the ground
and then that becomes the British
tradition in philosophy it does tighten
up the scientific attitude and
eventually it'll lead to saying well you
do need to try to measure things that
you can measure so that we can agree
upon them right you should try to apply
science William James you know American
psychologists watch later on he called
himself a radical empiricists a science
often times when the scientific attitude
towards things walking left out
important areas of our experience but
that would just be saying well we didn't
be broader than what we count as
experience but it would all come down to
experience and then what we do with it
yeah does he go into too much detail so
that's pretty much psychology as for
status of it right bringing up the
person yeah
just going too much detail endeavour was
it just from an educational standpoint
of what we should do or oh he gets into
the what he thinks are the nuts and
bolts
he wants to say how the processes work
how do we how do we form this idea like
how do we connect together impressions
of color with with you know impressions
of hardness and solidity so that we can
get going and say this thing is he's
he's doing what we call pistol nology
which is concerned with
how we know things to be the case and
what we can have serve me about that the
processes are which overlaps with with
psychology to some extent you can say
and he is also doing metaphysics which
is saying what is one of the things
really painted and how did cause in fact
he thinks that that's very mysterious he
thinks we can't actually get at the
substances themselves we can only we can
only know how they affect us so so we
can never really get to the absent
substance of gold but we can we can
certainly say things about its qualities
and we can say enhancer on
characteristics it interacts in
different ways like they were really
impressive the fact that gold wasn't
eaten by certain assets and that's what
he brings up over and over and over
again yeah
so so it is it does coincide with some
psychology psychology to come out of
philosophy and at the time that he's
writing it's not any it's not a separate
discipline like doing its own thing over
here it's just hurtful oddly yeah what
else there was a another idea I wanted
to bring up was personal identity this
is something that that's very important
and Locke made a very interesting
contribution here so when we talk about
personal idea we're talking about what
are you or who are what makes you you
like if we you know we had all these
sci-fi sort of things like taking his
brain out of his his skull we plunk it
into his skull like they do in cartoons
or cheap sci-fi movies does that mean
that his body now belongs to you and
vice versa or if we had some sort of
weird you know mine switching thing like
you see you know usually electrodes or
like Freaky Friday we do the same thing
and your consciousness is in his body
that's you right that consciousness or
as where as the body of you is that what
really constitutes your personal
identity that's what some people
Locke says well it's not really either
the self doesn't depend on substance he
says it it's not the soul it's not the
body
it's the consciousness so your
consciousness of yourself is what makes
you you were the same person we
continued in existence than the same
person insofar as our conscious past
how's that through through memory right
you guys remember coming in here you
presumably know who you are you've used
the same game over and over again you
probably can inside it you know same way
each time and then you know sort of
projection predict projecting into the
future if you have like your hopes your
dreams plans all those sorts of things
that's what makes you you and it's what
it's based on is this repeated action of
thinking so if you start tinkering with
that like let's say if you guys all see
into the Blade Runner the original one
with Harrison Ford Sean Penn right
replicants they've been given fake
memories memories that are somebody
else's childhood now how exactly they
got these fake members who the hell
knows you know that's never explained
not in another book that was based on
out of the movie you just have to kind
of you know go along with it there well
the so assume that they can do that
right you've got somebody else's
memories and you're working with them so
you've never seen that Beach you never
have that puppy you're never again stung
by that loss that's some other person
who did that but they are your memories
now because they're you they're part of
your personal identity they're part of
your continuity of the new memories that
you formed like thinking about those
memories like remembering you know the
wash gym you're walking or how you see
another wall I don't want to over there
that that stings me you've incorporated
that
who you want and so Locke is saying
that's really what makes a person a
person now there's some pretty important
implications of this person who can't
remember anything not really a person
anymore are they if you take this in
very strict sense somebody who isn't be
conscious person so you know you might
not you might want to add something else
to this story how you feel about that
but those are and so these are some of
his key ideas I did want to say it very
briefly because I don't want to on hear
about some of his influence so we talked
a bit about you know funding father's
his influence here in the Americas he
also thing and also he's you know one of
the founding fathers you could say and
the whole British and purist tradition
which goes through psychology as well
but he also was influential in other
countries interesting well tear is a big
fan block there were all these lock
Ian's in France who are using his
psychology to try to you know explain
how you know human cognition work and
they're part of the background that
leads up to the French Revolution I
think for the most part as influences
within what we call the Anglosphere the
english-speaking countries
understandably so because in English but
it didn't have a lot of impact outside
of it as well so this is a good place to
take any last questions comments no
nobody didn't and that's you know and
that's I mean it's not unusual among
philosophers especially at the Athan
Rene Descartes never did Hobbes ever did
Spinoza never did but it was kind of
unusual for guys at that time you know
you know one of the things that he then
he had to get a special dispensation to
not you know like
the ordained as a clergy member with the
schooling's attending but then he didn't
make any use of it all include you in
the Church of England they did there's
no important love affairs or anything
like that that we know of
they card actually had like an
illegitimate child not like anything
else I would have viewed military
authority it is social contract
oh so the military you know they're part
of the executive right but you've got to
be really really careful with them
because they they can become the tool
for the executive to like take out the
legislature at that time a lot of people
were pretty against what they called
standing armies you know in part because
all you had to do is look at what people
did with these stinking armies and so
yeah I mean what about like today's
military today's military is part of the
executive branch right because we have a
department of our defense I mean it's
interesting if you think about we have
all of these entities like you know the
military the State Department's
Education Department and they wind up
taking on this institutional life of
their home where they can sometimes have
culture and they can make decisions that
are at cross-purposes with the larger
society and with Congress and even with
the presidency you know like when George
Bush came in one of the reasons why he
had trouble getting things done during
the Gulf War there was this great
article about like you know somebody who
like at the State Department is looking
at the parking lot and it was just a sea
of bumper stickers for his opponent so
you know like these guys were not going
to yeah so you know how how do you look
at that is military you know just that's
another thing to think about
we will often conceptualize our
present-day institutions as if they you
know they were the same as this stuff
going on back then radically changed
think about education we they did a
public education back in at that time so
his remarks concerning education are not
about like what we ought to be doing in
K through 12 you know and how we should
help ETA or school like that should
decide things but you could use
any other questions are on us
well thanks very much for
good questions discussion hopefully you
get something out of this
you